en un primer momento en campaña se
refirió a esto a pasar por encima a
realizar referéndum como una forma de
gobernanza sin embargo creo que ahorita
estamos viendo un detalle importante y
es que el discurso presidencial está
mostrando un cambio entre entre el
presidente en campaña y el presidente
ahora electo vemos un discurso más
conciliador un discurso que busca
alianzas que incluso pide este en cierta
manera una negociación con el partido
que quedó en segundo lugar con él pero
que también es el partido con la banca
más grande dentro de la asamblea
legislativa entonces estamos viendo que
tal vez podemos estar frente a un cambio
de verdad de candidato en campaña pero
sus candidatos ya electo un candidato
que ya electo es consciente de los días
cosas consciente tal vez de lo que
implica la negociación y la realización
de acuerdos para lograr generar
gobernanza dentro del sistema
legislativo así como existe un ejecutivo
entonces podemos ver ese incluso como
nos decía alejandro y una gran ventaja
de costa rica es que tenemos este gran
sistema de pesos y contrapesos y una
institucionalidad muy sólida
su división de poderes que está frente a
rodrigo chávez entonces si en si en un
determinado momento el presidente
propusiera de verdad realizar estos
acuerdos desde realizar por ejemplo
referéndum pasar por encima a la
institucionalidad pues después tenemos
una institucionalidad bastante fuerte
hasta el momento entonces podemos tener
verdad un sistema de contrapesos que nos
puede proteger a los ciudadanos sin
embargo también los sistemas y la
institucionalidad democracia democrática
siempre sabemos que está en riesgo es un
donjuán es asumirla como hecha o no
podemos asumir la verdad como estable
sin embargo podemos defenderla y podemos
también tenerla por lo menos tenemos los
mecanismos para una una correcta defensa
ante ante cualquier propuesta que pueda
ir en esta rama autoritaria pueda ir en
esta mamá populista